depuis deux mois ça a aidé à ce jour se
prépare pour un marathon
et pas n'importe lequel celui de boston
l'un des plus prestigieux mais aussi des
plus exigeants du fait de courir tout
les jours avec une journée de congé le
défi est symbolique puisque sayyed a été
blessé lors de l'attentât à la grande
mosquée de québec il y a deux ans la
course est devenue un exutoire
c'est bien remèdes naturels île
fantastique si les remèdes
qui sont à la portée et qui dégage les
idées noires
mais le marathon de boston n'est pas un
choix fortuit en 2013 un attentat
terroriste a secoué l'événement trois
personnes sont mortes
deux cent soixante quatre autres ont été
blessés depuis l'organisme one world
trang a vu le jour pour soutenir les
victimes d'actes violents partout dans
le monde
[Musique]
c'est à l'initiative de défaut sur le
président de oneworld strong que saïd
participera au marathon de boston
ils se sont rencontrés en 2018 à la
première commémoration de l'attentât la
grande mosquée jamais pensé que ça va se
réaliser en cessation 2019 que ce rêve à
la réalité de saïd des fortes sur la
comprend lors de l'attentât au marathon
de boston
il s'apprêtait à franchir le fil
d'arrivée quand la première bombe a
explosé
il se souvient d'avoir ressenti la
chaleur et l'ondé de choc
blessé à un pied il a aussi perdu de la
capacité auditive à cause de la
détonation
en créant oneworld strong il voulait
rassembler toutes ces personnes qui ont
vécu un événement du même genre que je
suis né à boston saïd courra donc aux
côtés d'autres victimes d'actes violents
ou près d'eux ils comptent aller
chercher de l'énergie est aussi partagé
sa propre expérience
j'espère revenir avec quoi de beau temps
à l'intérieur de toi
son objectif finir le marathon à la
course sans jamais s'arrêter ici
alexandre duval radio canada québec